hands of stone stars Edgar Ramirez as
Roberto durán legendary boxer and tells
the story of how he's trained by Rey
Arcel played by Robert DeNiro and his
legendary bouts with Sugar Ray Leonard
portrayed by Usher as well as the
difficulties he has in his family life
trying to come to terms with the way he
was raised and the environment that he
grew up in and all of the hardships that
come with that De Niro of course is one
of the best but sometimes he's in great
movies and sometimes not so much and
Ramirez for me is one of the actors that
I've been watching ever since the Bourne
Ultimatum I'm really curious to see what
else this guy does because I think he's
terrific this is a very conflicted
character that he portrays in this movie
it's not exactly the most likable person
and the movie is actually pretty ballsy
and that it presents a character that is
wholly unlikable in many scenes and
someone that you have a tough time
rooting for because he really gets
himself into a lot of crappy positions
and it's always his fault and it's tough
to really get behind him and I think
Edgar Ramirez really did a fantastic job
for traying this conflicted character
and I thought it was one of the best
parts of the movie in fact for me the
best part of this movie were the scenes
between Ramirez and DeNiro the movie
southpaw directed by Antoine Fuqua
starring Jake Gyllenhaal that came out
last year did a very similar thing you
have a main character that's sort of on
top of things then there's a downward
spiral into hell and he builds himself
back up again that film was far more
riveting because it understood where the
heart of the story was similar to Creed
for me the heart of that movie was the
interplay between Creed and Balboa and
that movie knew that hands of stone is
more unfocused than those films it has a
harder time harnessing its story into
one flowing beat at times I felt like I
was rooting for Duran we saw the way he
was brought up and you feel like you're
behind him but then when he lets the
money and the power and the fame get to
him he start to actually be more on the
side of Sugar Ray Leonard portrayed by
Usher and it didn't focus enough on what
was actually the heart of the movie De
Niro and Ramirez and these two excellent
performances that was easily the best
part of the movie and the movie just
didn't give me enough of that I think uh
sure was just fine as Sugar Ray Leonard
but I don't really think he is an actor
at the caliber of De Niro or Ramirez so
having him in this film portraying Sugar
Leonard who's in the middle of a really
intense conflict with Duran that just
didn't really work as well because
Ramirez is just a better actor in almost
every way and so that conflict didn't
feel as compelling as it could have been
the boxing sequences are fine but
they're nowhere near as good as southpaw
and especially not Creed and not even as
good as the most recent rocky balboa
film that sylvester stallone had
directed from a directing standpoint
it's fine it's serviceable it's a boxing
b-movie that you might watch one day if
you have nothing else to do as a story
it's a bit scattered but you watch this
movie for the performances and for that
reason I'm going to give hands of stone
a C+ you don't really have to rush out
and see this one maybe wait till it's on
blu-ray or you can stream it on Amazon
video or something guys thank you so
much as always for watching I want to
make sure you guys know that my
promotion with crunchyroll is still
going on if you go to the link that I
have left in the description below you
can get a 30-day free trial of crunchy
rolls premium service that's ad free
anime sometimes an hour or two after it
streams in Japan we get it here they
have thousands of titles at your
disposal at your fingertips I'm a huge
fan of anime so I always want to back
crunchyroll because these guys are
making it a lot more widely accessible
to us here in America and I love that
please visit the link in the description
below for a free 30-day trial of their
premium service you guys are the best
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes